the castle is your home now so you can
go anywhere you like except the West
Wing what's in the West is forbidden
[Music]
Beauty and the Beast fans get ready
we've got ten theories that makes so
much sense they'll change the way you
see Beast and Belle from here on out
watch until the end to find out which
Disney movie Belle's favorite book is
referring to a provincial time loop
isn't it weird that no one in the
village remembers that there is a castle
in the forest right there next to the
town perhaps The Enchantress who put the
spell on the prince also worked her
magic on the nearby village maybe they
are stuck in a time loop Val and Maurice
seem to be unaffected by this spell that
would explain why Marius is perceived as
crazy and why Belle can saunter through
the little town without looking up from
her book the prince was just a kid if
you look at the timeline in Beauty and
the Beast some things just don't add up
when the Enchantress cursed the Beast
she said the curse would last until his
21st year later Lumiere and Cogsworth
stage that would make the prince just 11
years old when he was cursed that's a
pretty harsh sentence for the
Enchantress to carry out on a child
the enchanted portrait we've established
that the prince was only a child when he
was cursed by The Enchantress so why was
there a painting of him as a man in the
castle one fan thinks that the portrait
is cursed he believes that the painting
ages alongside the Beast showing him
what he would look like as a human with
each passing year Cidade owling is The
Enchantress incredibly harsh but she's
also downright cruel beasts would have
to look at that portrait every year to
see what a handsome young prince he
could have become a warning even in
small French towns bigotry is a
dangerous thing
the townspeople have ostracized the
Beast calling him a monster and
attacking him with torches
Gaston the biggest bully in the village
is hailed as a hero amongst the
villagers meanwhile beast is up in his
castle all alone without a friend in the
world no wonder he lacked proper social
skills
luckily Belle came along and showed him
what true love really was and the story
of Beauty and the Beast showed the world
how dangerous bigotry and hatred can be
the Rose when you think about that magic
rose from this perspective it changes
everything
one fan suggested that the Rose in beast
castle isn't wilting according to the
duration of the curse instead it's a
countdown to beasts ultimate demise the
Rose perceives that if the curse was not
lifted beast and the servants in the
castle would not survive the Rose was
actually wilted in response to this
doomsday for everyone in the castle
that's the reason the last petal falls
when Beast takes his last breath then
Belle's love broke the spell just in
time they'll hallucinates the whole
thing one fan theory states that Belle
is actually schizophrenic and
hallucinates the whole story The
Enchantress is one of Belle's
personalities trying to blow off the
aristocracy that was so disturbed by the
state of affairs in her town that she
started disassociating with people
turning them into clocks and
candlesticks in her head the magic of
the castle could have all come from
Belle's disturbed mine of course she
would make herself the hero who saves
the Beast
a figment of Belle's imagination another
fan believes that Belle is not crazy
only very imaginative it's established
at the beginning of the film that Belle
absolutely loves to read fairy tales if
thou were actually forced to marry
Gaston she would have a good reason to
make up a better story in her
imagination so when Belle brings home
her favorite book she injects herself
into the story to escape her own reality
then she can live happily ever after
just like in her storybooks chips baby
daddy this fan theory makes a lot of
sense when you think about it
Disney fan amanda menon thinks that
there's a reason chip calls a teapot who
is old enough to be his grandmother
mommy
could chip be the illegitimate son of
the prince and The Enchantress that
would explain why mrs. Potts who is too
old to have a child so young would care
for chip as if it were her own we all
know what the Enchantress did to the
Prince mrs. Potts probably wanted to
protect him from the beasts wrath
Gaston saved France from evil chickens
do you ever wonder why Gaston eats five
dozen eggs every day
redditors have a theory about that as a
theorist puts it during a period before
we me fell and the story begins France
had a huge feral chicken problem they
terrorized the people of France until
one young lad stepped up to defeat all
the evil wild chickens since he was
capable of consuming so many eggs he got
the chicken population in check sure he
developed a severe egg addiction and
subsequent personality disorder but hey
he saved France the end of Gaston means
the end of the village if you follow the
chicken hero theory then gasps Stan's
demise becomes a big problem for the
people of the village who's going to eat
all those eggs now that Gaston is gone
it's right there in the song no one eats
like Gaston so after he falls from
beasts castle the villagers are on their
own hope they saved all those torches
and pitchforks Belle's favorite book
fans believe that Belle's favorite book
is actually a reference to another
Disney film when Belle is telling the
owner of the bookshop about her favorite
book listen closely it sounds a lot like
another classic Disney animated film
[Music]
sounds familiar if you thought of
Sleeping Beauty you're right on track it
spells all-time favorite fairy tales
which fan theory is your favorite tell
us in the comments be sure to subscribe
to the things channel to be the first to
see our latest Disney Theory videos and
give this video a big thumbs up if you
like Beauty and the Beast thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]